hello I'd like to tell you about
erasmus+ the new European Union funding
program for education training youth and
sports erasmus+ builds on the success of
Erasmus the hugely popular EU student
exchange program but it's bigger and
better with a budget of nearly 15
billion euro that's 40% more than now
Erasmus plus we look for more
international opportunities than ever
before over the next seven years more
than four million people most under the
age of 35 will receive a Rasmus plus
brands to study work train or volunteer
abroad you can be a part of Rasmus blast
if you're a student teacher apprentice
volunteer youth leader or if you're
involved in grassroots or with this
program there will also be more
international exchange opportunities for
non your students and teachers
in these difficult times it will boost
your employability by improving your
language skills adaptability and
self-confidence it's a chance to meet
people from different cultures and to
discover new ideas and new ways of
thinking and living and believe me the
memories of this experience and the
friends you will make will stay with you
forever regardless of your age or
background erasmus+ will challenge you
to reach your full educational and
professional potential so what are you
waiting for visit the erasmus+ website
to see how it works
and what grants are available in your
country and get ready for an
unforgettable journey
you